[Musique]
j'ai commencé le cyclisme sur piste
quand j'étais jeune
justement pour me perfectionner en
cyclisme globalement et j'ai très vite
adhéré
adoré faire toutes les disciplines qui
sont lit en lien avec le sprint donc la
vitesse est assez vite le keirin et
j'aime beaucoup les épreuves par équipes
aussi sur la paix mon meilleur souvenir
en carrière je pense que ça reste et il
ya des chances que ça ça reste sa toupie
en matière c'est la première médaille
que j'ai obtenus lors des championnats
du monde élite c'était ici en 2015
devant un vélodrome rempli
en plus de ça c'était le dernier sprint
du championnat puisque jeu on a couru
une belle donc c'est à dire qu'il y
avait 1 1 avec moi contrairement à
l'adversaire et c'était vraiment le
dernier sprint du championnat après mois
ont ils ont éteint les lumières presse
donc une vraie belle image mort j'en
retiens énormément d'émotion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les objectifs pour la saison qui vient
évidemment les jeux olympiques
en ligne de mire qui seront en août
prochain avant cela il y aura une manche
de coupe du monde début janvier
il ya aussi les championnats du monde en
en fin février début mars sur lesquels
j'aurai à coeur de bien figurer puisque
j'ai un maillot de champion du monde à
défendre on a une médaille en vitesse
par équipes à défendre aussi donc
j'espère aussi être très performant sur
l'épreuve du keirin